Wow Star Wars Battlefront reminds me why
I love Star Wars
it's skirmishes unfold across iconic
planets gorgeous landscapes and sweeping
vistas on a massive scale endures trees
dwarf us tattooing desert stretches for
miles and when the battle music reaches
its peak and I glide over hops frozen
trenches I remember the first time I
watched that scene unfold but Star Wars
Battlefront lacks the longevity that
makes its source material great
it offers initial engagement and for the
first 10 hours it swept me through its
harrowing firefights at a rapid pace
but then the cracks began to show in the
end battlefront feels more like an
homage to Star Wars than a substantial
Star Wars game in itself and yet what a
beautiful homage this is dynamic
lighting vivid textures windswept
forests developer dice has crafted a
nuanced detailed world begging for a
closer look enveloping you at every turn
this is all stunning of course but it's
battlefront sound design that truly
reels you in with ambient wildlife and
booming explosions it speaks volumes
that I considered turning John Williams
timeless score off just to hear the
detail in battlefront swirled this game
demonstrates a strong sense of place
maps look fantastic and as natural
landscapes they're appealing but they
often lack focus design offs barren
fields and part a sense of distance but
few creative sight lines there are
exceptions in some of battlefronts maps
however for instance tattooing blend of
exterior and interior environments they
create engaging battle from one match to
the next and make no mistake there is an
abundance of game modes here Star Wars
Battlefront offers a total of nine each
distinct in its own way for better or
worse there's a spectacular heroes
versus villains which plays out exactly
how it sounds as if a box of Star Wars
action figures came to life and unsure
of what to do next
resorted to violence then there's droid
run a unique variation of zone control
in which the zones shift locations
throughout the match and then there's
Walker assault
this is battlefront at its best Walker
assault offers the game's most emerging
gameplay and in contrast to much of the
game's combat elsewhere it lends the
sense of a bigger objective Imperials
escort their 80 ATS towards the base at
the end of a path while rebels attempt
to do every
their power to repel them that's economy
between objectives means a different
experience for both sides and with
numerous offensive and defensive options
battles can unfold with surprising
variety but just as many of battlefronts
modes feel uninspired glass and cargo
are just slight variations on Team
Deathmatch and capture the flag and they
don't feel much different than they
would in any other shooter cargo does
lead to fun situations though it
encourages teamwork and tactics to bring
the flag back to your base while
balancing the other team
reactions as well so in the end there
are several different ways to experience
the military side of the sci-fi universe
but few are novel past the first hour
much of this traces back to one
root-cause battle fronts combat can be
monotonous there are cases when luke
skywalker cuts through an 80 st or an
errant rocket collides with an unlucky
TIE fighter but these moments don't feel
as novel after battle fronts early hours
by and large combat consists of medium
range gunfights where opponents hold the
trigger for two seconds and hope they're
the one left standing I seldom felt as
if I was impacting battles or as if my
skill was planning any wider purpose
vehicle combat offers variety but not a
ton although x-wings snowspeeders tie
interceptors and the Millennium Falcon
all feel great with intuitive controls
and fluid maneuvers they don't always
play a huge part in combat airborne
vehicles fly too fast over maps that are
often too small in comparison so
strafing runs are often futile
however snow speeders are essential in
walker assault as their tow cables can
bring down the four-legged behemoths if
use right a tsts can also turn the tide
at crucial capture points across larger
Maps I wish more vehicles led to these
kind of thrilling situations dice does
implement a progression system in its
multiplayer with everything from
character skins to blaster variations
ion grenade stew homing missile
launchers some grenades do more damage
to vehicles while certain sniper rifles
fire more accurate shots aside from a
few standout items though such as the
jump jet which lets you leap across the
map and into the fray these unlocks
don't always change how you play in the
long run
trait cards which grant you perks like
radar masking or explosive damage
resistance are definitely the most
valuable options and acquiring them
really felt worthwhile they're gems in
an otherwise bland array of abilities so
if nothing else Star Wars Battlefront is
an exercise in pure spectacle laid out
in all of its neon glory I still can't
help but smile when Boba Fett's slave
one guns down three fighters in a row or
a snow speeder careens pass with flames
trailing in its wake the first 10 hours
are packed with these moments and it's
worth playing just to watch them unfold
but at the same time battlefront doesn't
go much deeper than its ambitious
surface appeal it front loads its best
content only to fading quality as the
hours roll by Star Wars Battlefront skin
is beautiful
but its legs are shaking and threatened
to buckle with time
you